so I have heard a lot of interesting
talks about the data science about big
data but neural networks how to produce
all of that then how to get unique
insights on the data I'm talking a
little bit about the next step what do
you deal with the data was once you have
to analyze data set how do you actually
take it to the public how do you create
apps on top of it and how do you create
visualizations on top of that and so
I'll be pointing out especially
challenges on combining different kind
of data source data sources and
different kind of data formats so bit
more on the engineering off for the web
and mobile apps side of the of the data
science part so quickly Who am I I'm you
ha I'm doing nowadays mostly software
architecture planning those systems and
by hard i'm still software engineer if i
if i write code i usually are right
python so it's the right conference for
me i work for a company called wired
craft we are digital product agency
about 30 people in Berlin in NYC and in
Shanghai we work a lot on data centric
projects not as much in the data science
part but more on the creating products
on top of data or sometimes about data
management and presenting the data so we
have been helping many built like many
research groups when they have the
research data they want to build
something on top of it and we help them
to create a strategy and build the
system and also design the user
experience and one of the projects was
for the World Bank where we worked on
the on the story on the world the open
data portal so just quickly what we do
strategy and product design develops
ui/ux data visualization weapon mobile
development and aps and micro services
and actually creating a open data portal
kind of nice
combines all into one package so that's
that's why I prefer that kind of
projects it kind of combines all the
interesting stuff to me I am currently
based in Shanghai it's very different
from Europe but the software engineering
feels the same they don't writing
Chinese actually the code so i can
understand something and i've been there
for three years now so one of the
projects we have recently been working
on is the revamped world bank open data
portal their old side was a little bit
outdated and it was not very mobile
friendly and based on our visualization
experience we created a new experience
totally from scratch and that we tried
to fit it both for mobile and tablets as
well as laptop interfaces so here's a
quick screenshot on just give you an
idea what I'm talking about creating
user interface that can combine
different data sets and you can select
what pieces of data you want to wish
your lies and everything is interactive
you can hover over those lines and you
can select filter data or directly on
the front end and you can also get to
the source data so it's it's very
important that while you are showing the
data you're actually also communicating
what are the sources for data and how
you can download the source material
some of the similar projects we also
have done data management systems for
example we worked on the day Myanmar
elections part of creating part of the
information management systems for them
so we have quite big projects just to
get some of the terminology right here's
one screenshot of one of the projects
were that was very chair special where
we created a choropleth map of the data
some of the important things is that we
made it interactive so that when you can
hover out on different sites you will
see effect on which part is Hoover it on
and you can see tooltips to give you
more information and you can also click
each of those shapes and other parts of
the user interface with
X what you have selected so that's some
of the magic of JavaScript what I will
talk about is how to create the systems
to visualize research data for
especially for the web how to take the
data and what are the steps you need in
order to create the beautiful user
experiences you need and I make some
especially remarks for the geospatial
data there's some tricky parts related
to that one and how do you actually
fetch fetch and combine data from
different sources and sometimes it's in
different formats and how do you manage
that all and I'll try to highlight some
of the potential problems you might face
if you are thinking about building
visualisations I can I just maybe at
this point ask how many of you have
built some visualizations for the
webview has actually published to
everybody so there's not that many but
it's probably good volumes for me then
maybe I can give you some confidence so
that everybody can start building those
so specific things to research data so
the case i'm talking about this is
research data where there's already a
limited set it comes out comes usually
from not that technical people they may
be did a little study or somewhere or
did the user study and the source
material might be in spreadsheets or
CSVs or something and probably it has
never been read with computer so there's
some challenges related to that usually
the heavy data processing is already
done for you i'm not going to touch on
the machine learning or any other that
cool stuff and it can sometimes even be
in excess spreadsheets and it's by no
means big data so there's no challenges
related to that one just the general
system architecture give you an idea the
thing that can
closest to the data science is the is
the data processor the one that has to
actually fetch the data and process it
and feed it to the database so if you
want to put complexity somewhere in the
system put it there database usually we
try to keep it as simple as possible we
pre calculate a lot of the things on the
data processor side so that the database
can be kept quite simple and doesn't
matter if there's some dublicate data
because it's one-way data for so it's
easy to manage the synchronization the
data interface is basically the HTTP API
in most cases again point of that is
just to give you access to the database
so keep it as simple as possible and
leave some work for the for the
presentation layer for the web print
diganme layer means the the web
application and nowadays javascript is
so powerful that you can do so many
things on the front-end directly
including filtering and all the kind of
interactions and and all kinds of
sliding so there's a lot of
possibilities to do on the presentation
layer directly and that's what the end
users care right they only see the user
interface so while you are producing the
data remember that user doesn't really
care if you have cool IPI it cares if
you have a cool user interface some
things about the data fetching the first
part first of all encoding it's rare
that you get everything in nicely
formatted utf-8 format and sometimes
even if you think that you're your
source data shouldn't have any encoding
problem maybe it's all a ski you think
but there's always some weird characters
or copy paste error or invisible
characters that are not utf-8 or or I
mean not a ski or something so make sure
that you have good validation step and
you take care of the source material
encoding from the start usually the
person who had create generated it he
knows what is the encoding so usually
have some way to know what should be the
encoding
expect the connection errors from remote
connections if you are lucky you have
some API endpoints that you can pull the
day directly directly from but rarely it
works fluid every time fluently so
expect the connection errors and be be
prepared to retry sanitization there's
always some kind of if if the source
material has not been programmatically
compiled before there's some probably
some kind of copy paste problems it's
normal to have like line breaks in
middle of the words or something
something weird like that you can see
everything once you see enough of these
research research data sets to the diet
type checking as early as possible you
can see some detector with a lot of
different kind of typos and also
unexpected things if you do the type
checking and typecasting early enough
especially stuff like dates it's easy to
have a half one date that says unknown
or just the unexpecting just do the type
checking as early as possible and all of
this is to use a useless if you don't
have a good logging or if you don't have
a good way to present the problems I
think earlier today it's somebody said
that it's good to break if there's any
kind of error and I think especially I
started the project if you detect any of
kind of warning just break it it will
force you to fix the problem and if you
just print a warning look somewhere
nobody will fix it example of the
typical thing that can happen is that
you have CSV file and it at first it
looks like it's all okay and then then
there's a word called unknown there and
this happens someone sometimes when the
research truly has unknown value and
they don't know how to represent it
sometimes so they just write it unknown
it's as an engineer is hard to predict
when this happens so you need a good
validation mapping by nothing I mean
usually for example cheer spatial data
you have some data that maybe refers to
countries and then you have a shapes
that have some IDs then you have to
somehow combine those two for geospatial
data there's iso 3166 standard that
actually standardizes the country codes
with either 33 letter alphabet or two
letters but it's not as simple as that
there's some a lot of disputed areas
around the world so if you haven't I
have to want to have a nice smooth
visualization that doesn't have any
holes in there you have to be pretty
careful on on the standards that you are
using for example some of the disputed
areas around the around the Middle East
and pay attention to coordinate systems
it's actually not that easy this figure
out what is the coordinate systems of
the shapefile you are using and one good
way to detect that is to install a QGIS
application on your on your desktop and
just load it in there and see if it
matches your base map and you don't
necessarily have to use the same
mappings as the source data uses example
if your source data uses the two litter
iso codes for the countries but you
maybe want to in the web user interface
in the URL you actually want to say use
the country names or maybe the three
letter to make it use more user friendly
so you might actually consider choosing
the how you use the mappings early on
and the process I'll try to not have any
code this is the only code I think I
have it's just quick introduction on
don't be afraid of the shapefiles it's
not very good standard and in the lab
library is not very good actually but
but this is all you need to read a shape
file and transform it into a JSON file
and just to go through quickly dear
Jason is the format that is standard for
web do you represent shapes and it's
actually pure Jason so you can actually
trade a Python dictionary and just dump
it as a JSON in the end so and the at
the top you generate the top-level
adjacent structure
then you get the phase names from the
shape files and then you just look
through all the records that are
different shapes for example different
countries on the shape file and then you
read the values from that record you zip
it up with the field names and make it
as dictionary then if you have any other
data sources you can just add them to
the to the Python dictionary and then
you create the Geo Jason feature
dictionary let then you in the end
append to the features list of the of
the Geo JSON structure and then you can
just dump it thus any other JSON file
and it will work you can load it very
easily to to map books or any other
application that reports dear JSON files
so it's it's very simple few things
about data transformation after you have
loaded up you have to usually transform
and think how do you want to present
represent it in your system use JSON
everywhere unless you have good reason
not to I think this in this conference I
heard good things about message back and
I agree it can be much more efficient
but Jason is much more standard for the
web tool so unless you have a good
reason stick to JSON everywhere usually
you see you Jason or top of JSON for
geospatial data the difference there is
that Tubba Jason is much more compact
and it does cool stuff like if you have
two features that are next to each other
and they kind of share the border geo
Jason have to kind of draw the border
twice but for turbo Jason it can
understand that they are the same and
then it just that close 11 line so it
can it can help when you simplify the
features you don't have those one pixel
breaks between the pictures if you use
double Jason it might sound a bit funny
that you might actually generate the
whole whole data set as an option like
for some cases because the source data
set is so small there's just limited
amount of
different combinations of visualizations
or or possible user interface options
that you can actually pre generate the
whole data set as a static files so you
don't necessarily even need an API to do
any data crunching you just generate for
example JJ's and files that already has
the data that the form that needs so you
can skip the API layer in some cases and
it's it's a bit more time consuming and
back end but it simplifies so much on
the on the API side and usually it's
good idea to combine the data directly
to the ghas and features as I taught
previous slide it's very easy to just
inject the data directly to the do that
gejjen so it makes it a lot easier if on
the front end to do present the data on
the on the map and try to keep the data
structure on the database as flexible as
extensible as possible just try to keep
it keep thinking what is the next step
after two months when it is ready what
will I add to it and usually it's
something like recommendations or
business intelligence or another data
set that might be a little bit different
so try to keep everything data-driven
make it make stuff configure
configurable on the database level and
the last thing that you have to do for
the web is you have to simplify the
faith the shapes usually the shapes that
you download as a shape files are pretty
big like 15 megabytes is normal so you
have to simplify it to be to be easily
usable map shaper that org is something
really cool that I used to just try out
how smoke I can make it they have a
website that you can just upload a JSON
and a geo Jason and then you just click
simplify and then they have a drag drop
slider that you can make it a symbol or
or complex as you want and then you can
download it and see how big the sizes
it's actually written in noches so they
don't have a python module but i think
python has some libraries that use the
same algorithms so
you got there open source page if i can
find out what algorithms they use to
simplify the shapes and you can actually
see that red dots where it's starting to
break it's starting to overlap some of
things because I have simplified it too
much so it's it's really nice tool to
just see what is possible by simplifying
the data interface also called the API
keep it simple it really doesn't have to
do that much we can do a lot of things
on the front end so some of the things
you want to do it do and it is just to
be the layer in front of the database
and make sure there's a valid queries
coming in instead of restful JSON API
there's now adays different alternatives
to that one of the problem with the
RESTful API JSON API is that its
resource paste you might have your data
in one IP our endpoint you have the
metadata in a different API endpoint
then if you find for example to two
different crafts with three different
countries you might have making up 15 15
calls to the RESTful API to combat that
there's things called graph ql or Falkor
I think Craig PL is made by the Facebook
guys and Falkor is made by Netflix they
are both based on the on JavaScript but
I will in the end give you a link that
actually they have a Python port for the
craft ql already so you don't have to 90
noches to use that and I think in the
next slide I will explain a bit more
what it does but it can reduce the
amount of requests to one exactly one
you just tell what you need and it
compares everything and returns in 11
API call and keep the API design tied to
the user interface and user experience
you are creating you don't need any
additional features on it and it's and
it just brings complexity where it's not
dated if you try to over engineer the
API and again keep it simple you will
see later on why it's important to keep
this part in
so that you can add features later on so
Falkor here's one example of Falkor what
it actually means to so what it means
that is you basically give it a JSON
graph say what I want and then it
compiles it all and returns it it uses
this kind of Jason path syntax to say
what it once on the top its bit more
verbose version of it but i simplified
it a little bit to basically if I want
the metadata for the Finland and I just
want the name field I just listed like
this and then I want the data for
Finland for the population indicator
from years 2001 to do home to the syntax
itself is usually a bit more complex but
that's basically what it did and you can
just add stuff you can make the Finland
as a list and you just say I want
Finland and Germany and China and you
send us as a request to the back end and
the back end can compile it all together
and just return you at Jason graph that
is neatly combined into one one one
structure so that is super useful and
you don't have to be scared of using
showing 10 different crafts on your
website because you can just ask them in
the same request so you don't have to
worry about it taking too many requests
some things about the user interface
this is probably a bit more challenging
part for the pythoness tests that are
here nowadays it's really powerful if
you know JavaScript and if you are not
really comfortable you don't know where
to start just pick one of the rain moves
or libraries we use a lot of react
exactly more like ecosystem in a library
than framework but if you want more
framework e JavaScript things for the
front end I would recommend trying out
angularjs or ember or irelia any one of
those are now nowadays very fully
fleshed and production ready systems
for custom visualizations we used III
usually it's I think for the data
science types that's probably their own
quirky way to represent some of the
things but it's it allows you to do
almost anything it gets a little bit
tricky when you want to do scalable
things and you want to add interactions
and you want to add layers and making
sure that everything is working smoothly
on our cases but it's doable but if you
if you have a bit simpler use case you
should consider maybe chart of jj's or
charlies to chase or c 3 that is
simplified version of the d3 that's
largely crazy nice and if you're just
prototyping I would just use those ones
you cannot control all of the aspects of
the visualization but they work very
well if you do anything related to maps
I would recommend map books it's really
good for serving the maps it has really
nice base maps that you can just lay
under the features that you want to
present and they have a macbook jas that
is built on top of leaflet that is very
standard and full-featured library and
best part about my books is that they
have really good user developer
documentation so just go to our website
and see their examples and you will get
started really fast if you're not good
with CSS use bootstrap or some other
framework for that and make interfaces
intuitive to use especially when you're
combining different data sets it's kind
of hard to keep consistent on the user
experience but for users it's actually
very important to keep the consistent
user experience and independent on what
is the state what what is the indicator
they are looking at or or what are the
countries they are looking at and make
everything clickable nowadays JavaScript
it will powerful it's very easy to
create interactions so make everything
clickable and they will play around with
your visualizations as much longer than
compared to then being static
and once you have the basics working you
can start adding cool stuff like
recommendations because you can process
the data on the backend and you can also
do pre-processing on the ranges of
values so you can adjust the scale speed
better so you can add a lot of basically
and adding more context after you have
the first prototype working and remember
to concentrate on user experience again
they don't care about your back-end
things or the raw data they just care
about what they see and what they can
click on here's an example of our search
box for the for the new upcoming data
worldbank org and we actually use the
fuzzy fuzzy search on the back end so we
check what are the indicators that match
the exact word and then later on we give
them options that maybe they made a typo
or maybe they want to click something
else though just giving them a lot of
choices and highlighting the ones that
they probably want to click and actually
on the on the same list if some country
happens to match also pollution we draw
all the all the data in the same search
box and do your interactive quick search
experience for them and one important
thing is that you don't you cannot
expect what the user wants so some
people just want to browse stuff so we
have the browse by country browse by
indicator and browse by data set they
can just click it and see everything on
the on the same page a quick
visualization list how are we on the
time okay I think it's good quick
checklist on the visualization what are
the items that are clickable before you
start implementing it decide what are
the clickable things it's it's very cool
if for the user point of view if you can
click around things and it moves around
or you can select other things on the
interface by just clicking and pay
attention to the number formatting this
means if you have data sets that have
millions and billions and thousands try
to have some consistent way of
representing that
sometimes it means that you have to
actually process all the data web data
things on the back end and then say what
should be the scale for this indicator
so for the visualization as I told it
can be a trick bit tricky to work on the
on different scales especially when you
go down to the mobile scale so if you
are doing with d3 i recommend you from
the beginning start thinking how do i
make it work on your small screens as
well as well as big ones because it kept
xscape it gets very complicated if you
don't take it into account decide what
to do with missing data it's it's not as
simple as you think and sometimes based
on the data that you are representing
you might have have to have different
ways to represent the missing data
sometimes you want to maybe interpolate
between the data spots maybe you want to
have a dashed line or maybe you just
want to have some kind of full stop
between those things and it it depends a
lot on what are the what kind of data
you have and some things that are kind
of easy to miss is should I show the
zero on the y-axis because it is very
easy to confuse the user if you just
show there were the values from 1000 to
1010 and then they think it raises from
the 0 to the 1000 because it kind of
looked like that on the on the
visualization so those are all kind of
small minor user experience things but
they can affect a lot on how the users
experience the actual data and leverage
colors but don't go overboard people
like colors on the visualizations and
they are actually really powerful on
separating the different kinds of
information or screen but it can also
get really ugly really quickly so be be
conservative but don't don't be afraid
to try out different things so I just
want to show this again see you guys if
you have some data that you want to just
start thinking just build it out it's
really easy to get started
building is out and that data processor
can just be your typical Python script
the database we actually use readies for
some of the things the simplest cases
because usually that you can fit the
whole data set into a memory and you
just do the key value database structure
and you pre process as much if so you
can so you can keep the database and
once you have the database really simple
you can also keep the data interface
really simple you just basically map
everything you have been database
through the data interface or the API so
keeping those simple and closely map
with the database structure helps a lot
to add things on the future and on the
presentation it can be a bit challenging
at first to get familiar with the
JavaScript frameworks but don't be
afraid nowadays it's they have really
good documentation and you can do really
powerful things on the front end so
don't be afraid to try and I'm pretty
sure you can get get a prototype working
or like this very fast and good pointers
that if you do it like this you can keep
extending it you can keep adding
features let's say you want to add a
search feature you can just modify the
add a new trader processor script and
add a new database table and add a new
endpoint of the data interface but you
don't have to touch any of the previous
stuff so it will it will have a scalable
way to add features as well as add
performance some of the resources you
should check we write a bit more about
the about how we built the world bank
open data side on our blog the back end
is actually nodejs so don't be scared
but you could as well do it with Python
as I told the API is not the difficult
part they have a project called graphene
python it started last autumn so I'm not
exactly sure how production release but
it seems really cool it allows you to
use the graph ql on the python mapbox
tutorials are really good at showing you
how to visualize geospatial data they
have really good examples you can just
copy the snippets and get sorry
really good nap shaper that's the
website i showed you that can simplify
the simplify the shapes and really miss
realize it in real time how how it
affects your shapes and they have a kid
up project that you can learn more about
what algorithms they use PI SHP is the
Python library you can read the
shapefiles it's not really perfect but
it works d3 calorie it really gives you
good view and what is possible that we
do with JavaScript and III so if you're
not sure what direction you want to take
just take a look at the gallery it has
really cool examples and World Bank open
data beta site is actually public they
are we are planning to release it
probably at some point but you can
access it with baited oh well banger org
with URL and thank you that's it okay
awesome thank you do huh and I think we
have time for a cup of questions yeah
use the first ready I think I got the
talk and I really liked all your tips
about keeping the UX simple I think it's
really easy to forget when you're
building it and you're so close to the
data that it's not as obvious to other
people had a question and around whether
you do much user testing and if so how
you kind of structure it to get the most
out of it I'm actually usually part of
the engineering part so it's not exactly
my experience I mean specialty but of
course I see it happening we tend to
follow this kind of a child methodology
and we try to push our products s as
ireland's possible to the staging sites
or our dev servers and usually it's
actually our clients that do the first
user testing and then maybe they
organize the user testing so we do some
user testing on our own but also it's
partially hidden from the engineering
team sometimes because we have the
product layer in in the middle but as I
as I thought that the philosophy is to
push something out as early as possible
and then let you trail users use it I
think that's the way to do it usually
another question hi one question because
we are dealing a lot with reports in
writing reports do you have any
experience like making something
slightly interactive but that can be
saved in the PDF and can be then the
transport of their own well we should
usually actually I didn't mention it but
it's quite common that our data
pre-processing pipeline actually project
produces different formats from that
that level already so we write the data
to database but we also save CSV files
of the data sets and the Excel files and
some other that we offer us
downloadables from the website so we
have different formats we use the
database to actually do the interactive
parts and then we point to the static
downloadables that are not quite as
flexible but they can get the complete
data set based on the based on the
screen they are seeing so maybe some of
the filtering is only on the front end
but they can download always the full
data set based on the static files on
the server okay then I would suggest
that we thank you again